Now we have to test this.
Let's go back to test provider once more.
It'll be helpful to parameterize our tests
a little bit more,
both for location and for date.
All right, now that we've
parameterized our tests,
Let's go back at looking into
our insert read provider.
For the weather, we're currently using
the raw content URI to query.
But we can also query on additional data.
By cutting and pasting this test,
we can try the test
with different query parameters.
We'll close the cursor
because it's good practice.
Now for our second weather query,
we're going to test
the first of our new URIs:
WeatherEntry.buildweatherlocation
and we can use
our new test location parameter.
All right. Let's try running this test.
And our test passed.
All right. We're going to
add one more test
with a slight variation on the query
using build weather location
with start date instead.
So, we're going to use test location
as well as test date.
And now, let's run those tests.
And our tests pass.
Now, sometimes it's useful
to actually demonstrate a test failure.
Let's put in a date
that's certainly going to fail: 20150624.
We would expect this test to fail.
Let's try it and indeed it fails.
So we're pretty sure that our tests
are actually doing what we expect them to.